[Musik]
eines der letzten tabus die menstruation
ist immer noch nicht gesellschaftsfähig
die periode ist politisch sagt diese
junge frau und hat ein manifest dazu
geschrieben
[Musik]
einer der großen künstler der schweiz
franz gerd wird 90
wir haben den maler der berühmt ist für
seine frauen porträts in seinem atelier
in goseck besucht und
[Musik]
einer mit politischer haltung der
kalifornische des mose musiker gregory
porter gab in zürich ein konzert das
alles heute im kultur platz
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wir kommen auf den kulturplatz heute
machen wir station hier in dieser
herrschaftlichen villa in solothurn hier
im historischen museum gibt es einiges
zu entdecken über unsere körpersäfte und
das passt bestens zu unserem schwerpunkt
der sendung die menstruation wir frauen
menstruieren im durchschnitt mehr aus
440 mal das sind mehr aus sechs jahre
ganz schön lange aber bitte keiner davon
je etwas bemerken
ich glaube wir frauen sprechen
öffentlich er über sechs aus über unsere
periode dazugerechnet
[Musik]
nikci
wir frauen zeigen unsere körper aber
niemals würden wir zu erkennen geben
wenn wir unsere periode haben die
menstruation ist vielleicht so was wie
das letzte tabu in einer ansonsten super
körperlichen zeit oder haben sie schon
mal gesehen wie eine frau ohne charme in
der öffentlichkeit einen tampon
auspackte aber unser blut gehört dazu
und macht uns nicht weniger
begehrenswert das wissen wir spätestens
seit den filmen von pipilotti rist nun
hat eine junge frau ein manifest
geschrieben unter dem titel periode ist
politisch dazu unser hintergrund beitrag
[Musik]
ein café bisschen vom blut dieser menge
verliert eine frau durchschnittlich
während ihrer periode
derzeit leben rund zwei milliarden
frauen die potenziell menstruieren für
die einen ein ewiges martyrium für
andere ein wunder der natur
für die meisten frauen und männer aber
ein tabu
auch heute noch menstruation ist ein
tabu das bedeutet nicht dass jetzt
niemand jemals darüber spricht so ist es
nicht ein tabu es etwas sehr viel
unterschwellig ist und teilweise auch
unbewusstes wir haben irgendwie gelernt
menstruation das ist eher peinlich das
sollte ich verstecken das sollte ich für
mich behalten
das macht mich irgendwie auch in dem
sinne versetzt sie mich in einen zustand
der nicht optimal ist
[Musik]
periode ist etwas freundliches das
versteckt werden muss dagegen kämpft die
24 jährige franka frei mit ihrem buch
periode ist politisch ein manifest gegen
das menstruation stubbs als sie ihre
bachelorarbeit zu diesem thema schreiben
will stößt sie auf ablehnung
ich dachte das kann doch nicht sein dass
ich mein wenn es so ein gegenwert sich
und es gibt so wenig darüber so wenig
forschung ich möchte ich möchte dieses
thema wachen und dachte ich bin auch
etwas gestoßen das möchte ich mit
anderen teilen und habe dann einen post
auf facebook abgegeben
in den sozialen medien und der ging die
ral tausendfach kommentiert und geteilt
erhält der beitrag der berlinerin
reaktionen aus der ganzen welt darunter
die einladung einer pakistanischen
aktivistin frank frye reist für ihre
buch recherche durch indien pakistan
bangladesch und nepal und trifft
aktivistinnen die gegen das tabu
ankämpfen
denn die folgen sind auch in diesem teil
der welt gravierend hygieneprodukte sind
teuer
wo sie fehlen können viele frauen
während ihrer tage nicht zur arbeit oder
zur schule leiden öfter unter
krankheiten auch nachhaltigkeit ist ein
problem binden und tampons aus
kunststoff verursachen abfallberge mit
dem tabu geht unwissen einher wo
unwissen ist entstehen mythen und mythen
führen zur stigmatisierung perioden blut
ist eine folge des sündenfalls es ist
giftig verderbt lebensmittel so hieß es
bereits in der antike
erst mitte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
wurde dies wissenschaftlich widerlegt
diese historischen mythen demontiert
franka frei in vielen religionen galt
die periode als etwas unreines bedrohung
für das heilige menstruieren de frauen
hatten zu gebetsstätten häufig keinen
zutritt
auch zur universitäten und einigen
berufen wurde frauen aufgrund ihrer
menstruation der zugang verwehrt
trotz sexuelle revolution haben frauen
gelernt über menstruationsblut spricht
man nicht die werbung zeigt noch heute
damenbinden verströmen blumenduft und
statt rotem blut tropft blaues g es gibt
keinen größeren kontrast als als von von
rot bis bis zu türkis blau was für
hygiene und sterile verhältnisse steht
und auch kein bild der realität
abzeichnet was ist so schlimm an roth
pipilotti rist die schweizer
videokünstlerin dagegen feiert die farbe
rot sie bricht das tabu wie viele
künstlerinnen vor und nach ihr
in vielen arbeiten inszeniert und
würdigt sie märchenhaft und humorvoll
die menstruation
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit roter farbe protestierten auch
feministische aktivistinnen in zürich
gegen den tabuisierten umgang mit der
periode
das problem liegt im patriarchat erklärt
ana beatriz schweiz struktur und der
männliche körper ich so ist normaler
norden und frau ist grundsätzlich
wichtig so spezieller und das heißt
alles was mit dem weiblichen körper zu
hat ich kann sich speziell was mich
persönlich aus noch sehr stark mit dem
thema wird so viel über frauen beträgt
aber wenn frauen selbstbewusst
anstrengend und über die menschen nation
redet dann ist musik dann ist es unnötig
und dann wird man das ansporn für
ministerin kritisieren
der menschliche körper ist die norm für
sie ein grund dass kaum zur menstruation
geforscht werde
es gebe wenig wissenschaftliche studien
zu körperlichen und psychischen aspekte
des weiblichen zyklus
dieses ziel scheint sie aber aufmerksam
zu machen dass menstruation ist ruhig
wenn station produkte mit einer hörte
mehrwertsteuersatz besteuert und das
heißt sie gar dazu quasi als
luxusartikel war sie auf die hohen
preise kritisierte auch franka frei seit
anfang jahr gelten in deutschland
tampons und binden nicht mehr als luxus
artikel sondern als güter des täglichen
gebrauch
dieser schritt wird auch in der schweiz
debattiert der nationalrat muss darüber
bestimmen es tut sich was
ich möchte mit diesem buch ein teil
einer bewegung seien die fordert dass
wir das menstruation stubbs brechen dass
wir aufhören frauen zu beschämen weil
sie einen zyklus haben weil wir sind
alle nur da weil es diesen zyklus gibt
ich habe deswegen ein manifest gegen das
menstruation stubbs geschrieben weil es
sich dass menstruation stubbs negativ
auswirkt und zwar nicht nur für frauen
und mädchen sondern auf die ganze
gesellschaft um den gesellschaftlichen
umgang mit der menstruation zu ändern
braucht es kleine schritte schottland
macht's vor
da gibt es ab sofort binden und tampons
gratis für alle
es lebe die menstruation
[Musik]
zum thema weibliche rollenbilder kann
ich ihnen noch einen tipp mit auf den
weg geben für morgen abend da läuft der
doc die chefinnen ein porträt über
weibliche führungskräfte und darüber wie
die macht und dass frau sein
zusammenpassen
[Musik]
er geht dabei um zweistellige begriff
das hauptquartier tvi kunden überhaupt
schon das thema als sie die arbeit und
beschäftigung zurück
die große frau gemeinschaft in solid und
ausrüster frauen und die sie zu langsam
muster und jetzt probieren also für wie
möglich informationen hypo group und der
welt natürlich auch frauen themen
angesprochen installation und so ein
auslöser ich möchte also innerhalb jedes
jeden monat das paar tag benutzt und
halo eine zweite hohen gibt dass ich
nach auch regungslos ich sehe dass ich
nachher dass sie gezielt nach bearbeitet
das thema im kloster ist ja mensch der
aktion oder die zugehörige binder
soziale kontrolle funktioniert also ich
sags also wenn wir im rohschnitt periode
kann das avantgarde der frau mutter und
hat man also quasi das ganze büro
bezirks gießen hat vier tage lang mit
dem hochplateau demonstration habe ich
nutze ich das mal wieder zurecht auch
geholfen hat dass das erbe hintergrund
also sich doch noch mit clueso und
einfach sich natürlich auch die absolute
kontrolle vermutet periode mich sind das
die haben jetzt gebilde aus dem kloster
also das ist etwas ist zeitlich noch
nachhallt machen eigentlich dass ich
noch gemacht und die sp-frau normale
bericht um so bucht wurde die behindern
und dass du dich ganz spezielle strikt
technik und diese daher beschäftigt sie
bitte bürger frau ich genau außerdem hat
sie absolute grund traube bei dir die
weltspitze kann also unbekannt und
natürlich möchte ich so lange kann ich
jetzt durch musik ein sozialplan trauen
oder das ist nachgefragt
es geht ja bis auf synonym für menschen
was ich daraus andere die darstellung
was haben sie da für anekdoten gesammelt
also interessant ist es nachher nur 150
euro bis ich das so eines tabus oder
sogar menstruation sondern und astrid
thors groß geschrieben hatte und jetzt
geht es für frauen aber nachher mit zur
geschichte gekommen weil sie mit dem
umgang ist und so und sehr offenen
bereichen eigentlich die generation also
verklemmten aufgewachsen ist und jetzt
plötzlich kann man darauf für darüber
reden und das ist sehr interessant dass
sich sammler nachricht bezeichnet und
die geschichte einer frau
[Musik]
am 8 märz ist frauentag und das ist auch
der geburtstag von franz gertsch das
passt ganz gut denn die frauen spielen
eine zentrale rolle im werk des großen
schweizer malers nun wird franz gertsch
90 wir haben ihn in seinem atelier in
roschek besucht man muss schon sehr
genau hinschauen bei franz gertsch und
zu erkennen dass es kein foto ist so
auch bei medici dem gemälde das nicht
etwa nach der florentiner groß dynastie
benannt ist sondern weil der bauzaun der
firma medici gehörte ein herrlich
heiteres gruppenbild von freunden und
die künstlerische geburtsstunde eines
der wichtigsten schweizer künstler
biografie
knapp 50 jahre später mit fast 90
gerd schmalz immer noch nur in der
malerei könne er ruhe finden sagt er
[Musik]
damit sagt nicht genau sagen ob foto
dagmar und der täter der der wolke
auftrag natur gestört dass wir überhaupt
nicht ich glaube das wird die ganze zeit
witze stück
[Musik]
für mich ja fast jeder haben auch unter
mir bitte das stück bietet mal wichtig
das ist böse und nzz eben glücklich und
wenn sie das jetzt gut gemacht frau ist
es apple startet auch zum teil von jeder
frau ist verlass ist
lange suchte gerd nach seinem stil
probierte allerlei von aquarell bis
abstrakt ende der 60 er dann die
entscheide
gerd will nur noch großformat ich und
realistisch der gerd fotorealismus war
gefunden
als vorlage dient immer selbst
fotografierte
schließlich findet er sein sujet die
luzerner kunst sie taucht in die welt
voll inszenierung verkleidung
rollentausch spiel mit sexuellen
identitäten malt das lebensgefühl einer
generation vibrierend lustvoll
melancholisch auch
die medici boys wahren leben wird gerd
später sagen
[Musik]
1972 wird er zur documenta 5 eingeladen
hier fotografiert er gerade kurator
harald szeemann es ist sein durchbruch
gerd avanciert mit gerhard richter zum
vertreter des europäischen fotorealismus
die internationale karriere zum greifen
nah
1976 dann der umzug aufs land nachricht
mit der wachsenden familie eine zäsur
noch dann die welt der singles mit der
lotto tschernobyl bis sie ist langsam
essen entschleunigung anstanden und nach
haben ist erwarte fraport ein neutraler
hintergrund über konnte er tätigkeiten
tögel langt in rißegg marc gerd die
großen wichtigen frauenportraits anfangs
noch energiegeladen wald in sich ruhend
abwartend johanna
und natürlich später auch silvia
mit diesem scheuen blick der haften
bleibt
und gosch entdeckt die natur aber das
kleine sprung ist sie vor der fraport
wird zur landschaft gerade detail
diebstahl von japan also sehr viel
grösseres mass wie landschaftliche
motive nachher in summe nachmittag dort
gewalttour größer und damit platz eins
schaffte class selber wunderbar im
liiert ist sie habe die in der sache
nach neujahr sicher dass dieses fehler
für den natur- oder ob die damals wie
heute nutzt gerd diaz als vorlage
die ihr großflächig projiziert so auch
bei den holzschnitten die er in den
späten 80ern beginnt
[Musik]
so hätte es weitergehen können
märz verkauft gut er arbeitet viel ein
jahr für ein bild sein potenzial für den
kunstmarkt ist groß auch weil seine
produktion überschaubar ist doch dann
die krise sein langjähriger galerist
verspekuliert sich entpuppt sich als
hochstapler verpfändet gab es bilder
gerd verliert viel geld und muss von
vorne anfangen
das vertrauen in den kunstmarkt hat er
verloren weder klar die stangen hatte
werden wir haben mittel stehen zur
rechten zeit kommt ein mit 10
pharmaproduzent willy michl und baut in
burgdorf ein museum nur für gerd 2002
wird eröffnung gefeiert
ab nun findet sich ein großer teil
seiner werke im museumsbesitz auch der
verkauf verteilt über die interne
stiftung abgewickelt
gerd will dass seine werke
zusammenbleiben und vertraut auf wenige
private sammler
vermutlich sind das gründe warum gerd
nicht sein ganzes kunstmarkt potenzial
ausgeschöpft hat
[Applaus]
gerd schmoldt an einer neuen gräser
trilogie noch im herbst 2020 soll sie
der öffentlichkeit gezeigt werden
auf all die gemälde die noch kommen
werden
happy birthday franz gertsch
[Musik]
keine ahnung was einer wie gregory
porter mit einem solchen spinett
anstellen würde aber ich bin auch sicher
es wären samtene töne der mann mit hut
aus kalifornien liefert uns mal jazzig
mal souligen songs und die sind warme
seelentröster
seit neuestem aber schlägt der große
gregory auch politische töne an so wie
du uns im gespräch
[Musik]
jazz und soul sind die zutaten die
gregory peters karriere zum
senkrechtstart verhalfen religiöser
gospel ist das fundament seiner musik
die schwarze kappe sein markenzeichen
das ist mein persönlicher stil vor knapp
zehn jahren veröffentlichte er sein
debütalbum davor war er footballspieler
koch musicalsänger heute mit grammy und
platin füllt er große säle
[Musik]
wir durften den california vor seinem
konzert in zürich treffen
was macht der erfolg mit ihm ich bin
immer schockiert wenn 1500 2000 3000
leute in einer stadt darauf warten nicht
hinzuhören
[Musik]
worüber ich wirklich dankbar ist dass
ich erfolgreich
viele platten verkauft haben und auf der
ganzen welt arbeiten konnte ohne mich
ändern zu müssen so rund lief es für
porto nicht immer in seiner kindheit in
bakersfield kalifornien musste er
wiederholt rassistische gewalt erleben
[Musik]
das war eine organisierte gruppe von
rassisten
sie haben ein kreuz in unserem vorgarten
verbrannt war meinen bruder angeschossen
als er von der arbeit kam
sie haben in bierflaschen ruiniert
sondern unser fenster geschmissen und
auch wassermelonen vermutlich nicht
zuletzt deswegen empört er sich
öffentlich über die rechtsextreme
demonstration 2017 in charlottesville
trumps reaktion auf die ereignisse und
trance politik im allgemeinen ein
präsident ist eine sehr polarisierende
person eher dämonisiert das halbe land
das ist eine unangenehme situation
ich wünsche mir dass die macht haben der
partei ihre wähler respekt und erkennt
es liegt dass wir alle amerikaner sind
alle farben des liegen erstaunlich
verhalten spricht er diese themen in
seinen texten an und setzt lieber auf
warmherzigkeit
das macht ihn vermutlich mehrheitsfähig
die zürcher tonhalle war letzten freitag
ausverkauft
doch aufgrund des corona virus kam der
erlass des bundesrates nur 1000
zuschauer zuzulassen
einige mussten leider ausgeladen werden
ich mache musik um das leben der
menschen zu verbessern
eine person kann ich die ganze welt
verändert aber ich glaube dass die musik
die ich mache
mit aufnahme und konzerten werde eine
positive energie
[Musik]
roters neues album all dies erscheint am
17 april
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die ausstellung hier im historischen
museums oder ton 246 und schokolade
läuft noch bis september dieses jahres
wir nehmen sie nächste woche mit und
zeigen ihnen wie ausbau abfall neue
architektur wird und hier folgt jetzt
gleich gartenbank im diamantenfieber wir
wünschen ihnen eine schöne woche
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja da war ja noch was der korona views
in norditalien sind inzwischen die
meisten kulturhäuser geschlossen
doch italien wäre nicht italien wenn es
aus der gramm der misereor nicht auch
ein lied gebe
[Musik]
die gigaset boris canje wissen
us dollar
[Musik]
paziorek mal antenne mit diepresse.com
diaboli marke priester situation
funktion wasserfall und pokale
unterstützung der panik
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen der kultur des
wissens
[Applaus]